Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and it's fall here in Alaska I'm
camping in Bushcraft survival shelters
hunting Grouse and hairs cooking up good
food and having a great
[Music]
time this is a place where I'd expect to
see a lot of Snowshoe hair or even
Spruce grous and frankly either one of
those sound pretty good for dinner
tonight there you go those are little
rabbit poops this is a great time of
year to hunt Snowshoe hairs cuz they
turn white in the wintertime and it's uh
right the beginning of winter but we
don't have snow on the ground here yet
so it makes it really easy to see a
white rabbit in all this brown just got
to spend a lot of time
looking
an invasive Beetle called the Japanese
Spruce bark Beetle has wiped out more
than 90% of the spruce trees in this
Forest large patches of forest in Alaska
have just been completely wiped out by
that
Beetle I can see a spruce gr sitting on
a tree branch up
ahead I definitely got
him so well camped
camouflaged oh there he
is look at that so this is the Spruce
grous and they are delicious like a wild
chicken but you can see how camouflage
they are when they are up on the ground
they are really hard to see see there's
a little marking on their eye a little
red got like a little red eyebrow the
grows have feathers on their feet to
keep their legs warm in the winter time
but they like to sit up in these spruce
trees about 68 ft off the ground and
you'll see them just like a ball right
there but you have to just look and look
and look this time of year there's
rarely just one of them I have to look
around really carefully and see if I
can't spot
more well I've got myself dinner and
this trip is off to a great
start at it
is check it out those are moose bones
right
there
that looks like a big wolf dookie see
all the hair in
it oh there's more wolf poop wolves
probably Patrol this Trail looking for
food sure's a lot of poo on
it oh this looks like a decent spot to
make
Camp carried this big old heavy tripod
all the way here and I forgot the
adapter so can't use it I have forgotten
so much stuff I feel so half coocked
today I forgot to bring paracord and I
forgot to bring any utensils or plates
or cups or anything like that so uh just
going to challenge myself it's all part
of the
fun before I get started on my shelter
I've got to do some prep for dinner I
brought some bread flour and yeast going
to make some bread but I got to let it
ferment for a little bit so I'm going to
start making up the dough right
now all right let that
sit I think I better start cutting
myself some trees I'm going to need a
lot of
poles yeah look at all the sap oozing
out of this tree it's from the spruce
bark beetles they drill tons of holes in
the bark and the tree trees just bleed
to death as far as the eye can see the
trees are just wiped out I can't see a
half a dozen live trees in this entire
Forest I bought this Hatchet last spring
on my trip to Japan no idea what it's
called but this thing is awesome for
taking tree limbs
off
it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the most timeconsuming part of
the whole process but if you use thicker
logs it goes much quicker but if you use
thinner logs they Flex a little bit and
it's easier on your
back
all right there we go
all right I got my bed made better get a
fire going I'm getting
hungry there you go there's just a
cotton ball with some Vaseline on it the
Vaseline makes it burn longer and hotter
and us cotton instead of Dyer lint just
burns a little
better there you
go beetle kill Spruce just goes up like
gasoline luckily it rained this morning
so everything's pretty wet you wouldn't
want to build a big fire like this
otherwise they're kind of like let the
fire spread a little bit and consume up
all the dry grass and sticks then you'll
have a nice bare spot that's safe to
build a fire you just got to watch it
like a hawk right
[Music]
now
all righty I'm going to get away from my
campsite and go clean this bird here we
go a couple pieces of grous breast meat
I was planning on plucking the whole
bird and cooking it over the fire with
the skin on but uh I had hit him a
little bit low with the 22 and it made a
bit of a mess
so
I'll tell you what if you're looking for
the ultimate survival Foods flour beans
rice those are hard to beat I mean this
is like two 3 days worth of food right
here in this bag it's compact it's cheap
it's non- perishable tastes delicious
got to love
it just let that simmer for a nice long
time well the beans going to take a
little while to cook so I'm pulling out
some slices of pilot bread some cheese
and salami I'm making myself a little
snack if you don't know what pilot bread
is it's a shelf stable cracker it's
really thick and
hard I may have raided the kids
Halloween candy a little bit last
night see I got the bread dough here
let's give it a smell oh yeah it's
fermenting fermenting slowly because of
the cold put the dough up here here let
the heat of the campfire warm it up a
little bit that'll speed up the
fermenting
forgot all my utensils so I made a
quicky
spoon oh that's looking good let's just
s it right there to
[Applause]
warm
all right I use my griddle as a plate we
got my
spoon we got some
bread oh that smells delicious may not
look fancy but I'm excited to eat
it wild birds like grow are so
incredibly lean that if you cook them
like chicken you'll completely ruin them
they get very dry you got to cook them
like steak you want a little bit pink in
the
middle got a little hot sauce here going
to put on my
Grouse a little bit of my rice and
beans that was delicious it's amazing
how good those beans taste just onions
garlic salt and butter that's all I
added so good I am very full I just fin
finished dinner and there's a few
snowflakes coming down I think I better
get my shelter finished and get in
bed well I think I got the shelter up
just in time it's starting to
rain here we
go these pine trunks are always a little
bit Pokey and I'm always afraid they're
going to pop my air mattress so I laid
This Grass down to kind of give me some
extra insulation and some
protection this is my pillow it's a
waterproof bag and it's got this fuzzy
lining on it you just take your jacket
and shove it in
there well it is late and I am tired I'm
going to go to bed I will see you guys
in the
morning hey guys it's about 2:30 in the
morning and there is a large pack of
coyotes out out around my
Camp I can hear him laughing and barking
off to the left and then over to the
right all right I'm going to try to get
some sleep we see if they come in Camp
and mess with anything all right good
night
well good morning I didn't sleep very
well last night I kept getting woken up
by this a massive pack of coyotes they
were running in the woods around the
tent I first heard them over here on the
left and it was so many dogs it sounded
like a dog mushing kennel they were
doing their laughing and their whooping
and their barking around 2:00 a.m. they
were off here to the left and then they
worked their way through the woods in
front of the tent and then they got all
the way out towards the car is and then
sometime around 4 4: or 5 a.m. they came
back this way and this time I could hear
them behind the tent but but I kept the
fire going all night and as far as I
know they never came into Camp they
never bothered anything but keeping the
fire going all night burned up my entire
pile of wood so uh I need to cut some
more
wood cutting firewoods a great way to
get the blood pump in in the
morning I think it's time to make some
breakfast there we go fried
spam
a little pad of butter here we're going
to just melt all over
it just smearing some melted butter all
over my bread got a little bit of honey
here fried bread honey butter and Spam
The Breakfast of Champions right
there here that pack of coyotes started
howling over there
again that is a fabulous sweet and
savory flavor got the grease and the
honey oh fried spam is so
good that was so delicious well now that
I got a little food in me I think it's
time to clean up the campsite and go do
a little more hunting
you know this really was a nice bed and
I got to tell you the older I get the
more I care about having good back
support you know one thing I worried
about is whether or not a spark could
catch this dry grass on fire you don't
want to wake up in the middle of the
night engulfed in flames and melting
sleeping bags but I'm a little skeptical
about whether that's really an issue so
we're going to test it
out
that's a lot more than a little spark so
if those coals don't light it on fire I
think we're
okay I think you need the combination of
Sparks and wind for that to light on
fire certainly isn't going up like a
blazing
Inferno it's been a fun little campsite
but I think it's time to put the fire
out and go
hunting the things I'm hunting like
rabbits grous and Tagan they all live
off of these Willows see these things
and you tend to find a lot of these
Willow patches on the edges of trails or
roads so you just walk down these Trails
slowly and look spend lots of time
looking well I've covered more than a
few miles and haven't seen anything but
we had a good day it's been a fun trip
and hopefully you guys enjoy watching
this if you want to see more videos from
the outdoor Boys YouTube channel make
sure to click subscribe and check out
our playlist we have all of our videos
organized by playlist all right guys
I'll see you next video If you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for
watching